réconforter les parents les trois soeurs
et les membres de la famille de yoann
lavenère la victime et la démarche de
bon nombre de personnes ici à la maison
familiale au quartier et wierre aux
manettes d'un auteur de cette marée
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquète
il semblerait que des nuits de samedi à
dimanche que yoann et sa compagne qui
réside à malakoff ramené un beau frère à
son domicile à vitry-sur-seine dans le
val-de-marne alors qu'il s'arrête à un
feu rouge le véhicule est pris à partie
par une bande d'individus qui balancent
des projectiles
le pare-brise cassés yoann dégagent les
débris de place il descend du véhicule
étant tout de même le dialogue avec ses
agresseurs et c'est lorsqu'il retourner
dans sa voiture donc ils lui ont tiré
une balle dans le dos et bien sûr mon
air et autres mésaventures et leur jeu
s'est passé il a démarré et sa femme a
vu qu'il lui faut que lorsqu'ils ont vu
ça ils l'ont descendu de la voiture et à
ce moment là il ya je crois il ya
quelqu'un qui est venu pour lui faire
des massages des massages cardiaques et
à l'arrivée des pompiers les pompiers
ont repris la chambre la relève pour
pouvoir faire des animations
mais pendant plus d'une heure il est
d'ailleurs et de johann hay un père sous
le choc
il a encore beaucoup de mal à admettre
cette fatalité
un fils de 33 ans passionné de pêche
d'abord électriciens en quête de
stabilité professionnelle
il obtint son départ vers la france il
ya une dizaine d'années il a d'abord
vécu à 3 ensuite il est descendu en l2
france s'installe et n'a passé
sipa le concours mais il a posé sa
candidature à la ratp
longtemps que machiniste il était depuis
dix ans à peu près et c'était monte
c'était quelqu'un de très gentil très
serviable c'est tellement temps c'était
lui et moi l'enquêté est diligentée par
le parquet de créteil
la mer est une des soeurs s'envole ce
soir en direction de l'hexagone elle
espère que toute la lumière sera faite
sur ce terrible drame
une autopsie du corps sera pratiquée
dans quelques jours